DNA is a program a set of instructions
that tells a cell what proteins to
produce and then those proteins perform
the essential functions of the cell but
we can think of living cells as
miniature computers and essentially the
software that controls these cells is
DNA in the computer we have zeros or
ones which are the binary code in the
cell the DNA is quaternary coded for
letters we insert new DNA code into the
cells we can get them to make proteins
they perhaps wouldn't otherwise have
made in the same way we can take a
program for one computer and put it on
another we can take DNA code and insert
it into the cell a microsoft research
we've been developing a programming
language that allows a programmer to
write a description of what they want to
start to perform and the software works
out the DNA code that's needed in order
for the cell to behave in that way the
key thing about our software is that the
programmer doesn't have to know any DNA
code we're in the plant sciences
laboratory in Cambridge University run
by Jim Hasselhoff and this is where they
actually engineer the synthetic systems
that we design on a computer this whole
migration from what was a field of
biology and looking at biological
functions is moving directly into a
field where your information processing
computers allow you to produce a
blueprint for a circuit bigger build and
secondly they allow you to tinker with
the parameters of the elements in that
blueprint to give you an idea of how
that we perform ahead of the laborious
task of building it once the DNA code
has been synthesized into nucleic acid
sequences then those sequences can be
inserted into the cells and that's what
happens in this lab we can take DNA from
one cell for example a cell in a
jellyfish tells them how to make the
proteins that allowed the jellyfish to
glow in the dark we take that DNA and
put it into another cell for example a
bacterium then the bacterium will read
those instructions and be able to glow
in the dark
so that we write code which instructs
the cell to make a protein that sticks
to a signaling molecule and the
combination of the receiver protein and
the molecule then activates a protein
that flores's so the idea would be take
a sample of drinking water and mix it
with the cells and then if the water
contains a pollutant such as arsenic the
cells would then change color or 4s in
response well all of the technologies
that we need to feed ourselves to clothe
ourselves to provide materials for a
modern world derived from non-renewable
sources and we need to move towards
renewable sources and use sustainable
technologies and largely they're
biologically based and so the ability to
reprogram biological systems is hugely
valuable in that endeavor the ability to
manipulate cells lies at the heart of
our ability to understand disease
because disease affects cells and if we
can understand how the cell works and
reprogram how the cell work we could in
principle reprogram the cells of our
immune system to fight disease better in
terms of food yes our ability to
engineer essentially more efficient ways
of turning the sun's energy into food
could allow us to feed a growing
population in terms of energy again our
ability to transform the sun's energy
into biofuels or into electricity
directly could help solve many of the
problems we face today in terms of
providing energy for an increasingly
industrialized planet it's the way the
future we anticipate that in the next 5
10 20 years time this scale of circuits
that we'll certainly be able to produce
and will want to produce is far beyond
the ability of humans to model and that
will clearly require this kind of
technology so we're on a trajectory here
there's a close integration between
software design and modeling and
biological assembly